mais on va plus loin avec l'historien
françois durpaire dont jean françois et
bruno daroux la rédaction de france 24
jean bruneau les états unis vont donc
s'engager davantage encore dans la
guerre en ukraine c'est du moins ce que
souhaite joe biden il demande au
capitole de voter 33 milliards de
dollars supplémentaires pour l'ukraine
dont donc 20 milliards 1 d'armement ces
prêts à de cette fois les montants
d'armes et munitions déjà fourni à kiev
depuis le début de la guerre le
président américain se défend néanmoins
d'attaquer la russie écouter
malgré la rhétorique mensongère du
kremlin les faits sont évidents pour
tout le monde nous n'attaquons pas la
russie nous aidons l'ukraine à se
défendre contre l'agression russe et
tout comme poutine a lancé son invasion
brutale il peut décider d'y mettre fin
la russie est l'agresseur il n'y a pas
de doute là-dessus paru si l'agresseur
et le monde devra la tenir responsable
par les ponts sera la mise en garde de
vladimir poutine il ya le président
russe menacé d'une riposte rapide et
foudroyante tout acteur extérieur
tentaient d'intervenir en ukraine un
risque même de troisième guerre mondiale
avait prévenu lundi sergueï lavrov il
fait qu'elle calcule joe biden
d'après-vous françois durpaire la russie
n'a pas les moyens de sa rhétorique il
faut la contrainte par la force ou bien
au contraire méfiance la guerre
nucléaire et peut-être au bout de
l'escale joe biden il se dit qu'est ce
qui se passerait si vladimir poutine
s'en tirer à bon compte
c'est ça son idée en fait la première
chose c'est que pour que boot inn
l'emportent il aurait fallu qu'ils
l'emportent rapidement guerre éclair
mais les ukrainiens en quelque sorte ont
rebattu les cartes en résistant au tour
de kiev ils ont contraint les américains
à se dire que autre chose était jouable
et cette chose qui est jouable c'est de
se dire maintenant on n'est pas engagée
dans une guerre par procuration en
ukraine on est dans un conflit
géopolitique
de long terme et à large échelle avec la
russie est-ce que 33 milliards de
dollars
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas sûr
uniquement l'aide à l'ukraine mais on
est sur une perspective de long terme il
l'a dit d'ailleurs les cinq mois à venir
on n'est plus sûr demain après demain
sur une guerre qui va s'achever il y a
des c'est faut pas laisser croire que
les ukrainiens sont en train de gagner
la guerre mais en tout cas les
américains se lisent il est possible de
faire perdre vladimir poutine cela dit
c'est pas gagné les 33 médias puisque
c'est déjà bloqué donc déjà y'a pas de
33 milliards le congrès a dit là enfin
on suit les dépêches
c'est pas possible on ne donnera pas 33
milliards pourquoi on sait pas les 33
maires parce qu'il ya un consensus sur
l'ukraine c'est parce que
il a voulu jouer au plus malin joe biden
il s'est dit il faut aussi m'aider pour
mémo qu'ovide j'ai besoin d'argent aussi
pour ce courant tiko vide et ça les
conservateurs avaient prévenu si vous
essayez nous refourguer le coc vide en
même temps que l'aide à lui créé lier
les deux sujets même vote c'est çà et là
l'entourloupe sera trop grande ça sera
pas question on votera pas donc ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est que
c'est déjà bloqué au congrès ces 33
milliards qui vaille à devoir avoir des
allers-retours en dubaï dont on peut
toujours se dire effectivement je veux
sauver monde aide à l'ukraine donc je
vais dissocier les deux mais en tout cas
là il ya un blocage des conservateurs y
réclame une aide de colossales en tout
cas pour défendre l'ukraine bruno daroux
c'est pourtant bien joe biden qui le 20
janvier avait chuté jusqu aux
républicains en laissant entendre qu'une
incursion mineurs des russes en ukraine
ne serait pas forcément suivies d'effet
qu'est ce qui a changé depuis dans la
position américaine bat françois l'a
déjà dit un peu ce qui a changé c'est un
la résistance qui était inattendu de la
part des ukrainiens et ça même les
services de renseignement américains qui
étaient pourtant pas mal renseigné
puisqu'il avait prévu l'invasion ne
s'attendait pas visiblement cette
résistance il pensait que vladimir
poutine allait faire qu'une bouchée de
cette harmonie crânienne ce n'est pas le
cas et correia à ça du coup les manques
les faiblesses les les ratés de cette
armée russe qui s'est embourbé et comme
l'a dit lloyd austin secrétaire à la
défense ya deux jours une armée russe
qui a été très sévèrement affectée du
coup effectivement les américains sont
ni tiens il ya peut-être un coup à jouer
on va aider l'ukraine à la peut-être pas
à gagner mais en tout cas à faire durer
le conflit et à ne pas perdre à arriver
peut-être à une situation gelés et à
contraindre parce qu'il l'a redit
aujourd'hui quand même à contraindre
vladimir poutine d' arrêter cette guerre
et de revenir à une discussion
diplomatique parce que ça ça aussi une
île ne les cartes pas il ya trois choses
quand même kaki qu'il maintient quand
même joe biden s'est nous n'attaquons
pas la russie ça c'était peut être y
réponde et peut-être aussi à la gaffe
entre guillemets de lloyd aus team qui
avait dit notre objectif est d'affaiblir
la russie donc l'oeil de signes parler
directement à la russie dans un dans une
logique de confrontation donc là lui dit
non nous c'est pas la russie qu'on vise
nous nous défendons l'ukraine et puis la
voix divine avec le conflit bah ce
moment là on discute et la voie
diplomatique reste au possible mais en
gros c'est à lui de jouer s'il veut
arrêter de faire des bêtises en quelque
sorte si vous me passez l'expression
c'est à lui de jouer tant qu'il ne le
fait pas eh bien nous on est derrière
les ukrainiens au maximum en livrant des
armes l'eau tout de même à l'ukraine
washington ne craint pas d'apparaître
comme un kobe lit géant aux jeux de
moscou françois aux yeux de moscou si
clairement vladimir poutine va se dire
là en plus on a le détail de
l'artillerie
ddt systèmes de défense antiaériens des
capacités à peu près tout en fait quand
on fait la viste ya maintenant à peu
près tout il ya plus de séparation entre
arme légère ou lourde offensive ou
défensive c'est beaucoup d'armes et plus
les millièmes les mig en tout cas pour
l'instant oui voilà pour l'instant pas
encore mais il se laisse encore une
marge mais il ya les fameux drones de
nouvelle génération
c'est pas que ne sait pas que de
l'armement qui ont refourgué qu'on
n'utilise pas du côté américain on teste
aussi de nouveaux armements des
armements qui ne sont pas utilisés que
les ukrainiens pour la première fois il
ya de la formation donc évidemment pas
de bottes sur le terrain mais en tout
cas des formateurs sur le terrain pour
former les ukrainiens et puis il ya
aussi le début dans ses 33 milliards 20
milliards pour l'armement d'une
reconstruction industrielle de l'ukraine
qui s'est projeter déjà vers futur plan
marshall joe biden soutient également du
renseignement américain on sait que pour
l'instant c'était assez prudent l'aï dit
on va aller un peu plus loin dans le
soutien aux renseignements ukrainiens on
avait peur notamment des agents russes
infiltrés chez les ukrainiens donc on
craignait un petit peu ce rapprochement
alors évidemment possibilité
possibilités du coude après que va faire
vladimir poutine est là l'idée c'est de
se dire en mettant ce paquet 33
milliards sur la table ça rappelle un
petit peu ce que regan a fait pendant la
guerre froide un peu défier pas
seulement l'armée russe l'armée
soviétique à l'époque mais l'économie ce
vieil sous l'ailé russian dans la course
aux armements lourds 33 milliards ça
veut dire on est on est prêt à faire
fonctionner l'industrie ahmed on est
quand même le doudou plus que le budget
militaire de l'italie plus que le canada
plus qu israël puisque c'est
considérable 33 milliards donc c'est une
manière de lui l'armée française c'est
40 46 kg
on n'est pas la touche pause c'est
absolument considérable donc ça veut
dire que c'est un défi direct en même
temps il y avait les images de gouttière
et c'est important qu'ils disent images
ce jour là on va on va sans doute en
parler parce que la mairie classe e
place dans la situation de est ce que ce
sont les nouveaux gendarmes du monde ou
est ce qu'on essaye de rabibocher la
communauté internationale autour de nous
parce que le carburant des de ce que 10
de ce que dit joe biden s'est les images
que les américains voient quasiment en
continu de charniers de ces fameuses
images satellites là aujourd'hui deux
corps près de kiev et ça l'opinion
américaine allait doubler un aveu pas de
guerre et veut pas aller plus loin dans
le conflit mais en même temps elle est
absolument
traumatisés par les images qui lui
arrive d'ukraine wyatt il a une
coalition internationale autour des
états unis on l'évoquera dans un instant
mais mais si on regarde la même
l'allemagne sylvie bruno da où les
conservateurs ont joint leurs voix aux
sociaux-démocrates hier pour approuver
des livraisons d'armes à kiev c'est
l'ensemble des des occidentaux convoi
ans hardy d'une certaine manière face à
face à la russie oui alors on pourrait
dire un peu en a redit au départ par la
peur parce que tout d'un coup ils sont
dix mains cela ce que fait vladimir
poutine c'est du sérieux comme disait
l'autre et donc il faut absolument qu'on
réagisse lors la révolution
copernicienne de l'allemagne
effectivement très significative le
paradoxe d'ailleurs c'est que dans cette
affaire dans cette alors là vous avez
parlé des conservateurs mais dans la
coalition au pouvoir sociaux démocrates
libéraux et verts
en fait c'est le chancelier olaf scholz
qui jusqu'au dernier moment a été le
plus réticent à revenir sur cette
fameuse hausse politique alors
maintenant même que les conservateurs
s'y mettent du coup bon ça y est
l'allemagne non seulement annoncé un
effort considérable sur son armée mais
annonce là donc la livraison pour la
première fois depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale de 50 chars
guépard qui vont être envoyés on verra
bien comment ça se passe aussi on
l'ukraine donc oui il ya une côte et en
art dit il ya aussi on pourrait citer la
la suède et la finlande qui maintenant
c'est quand même un paradoxe quand même
de cette gare en ukraine vladimir
poutine est parti en gare officiellement
pour stopper l'extension de l'otan vers
l'ukraine et les résultats deux mois
après la suède et la finlande la
finlande qui ne jurait que par la
neutralité depuis les années 40 et bien
s'apprête à rejoindre l'otan donc en
mardi est effectivement pour le moment
deux mois après une europe plus solide
une dépendance énergétique à terme aussi
qui va être réduite de l'europe à bord à
la russie et ce ne sera pas gagnant
gagnant à long terme pour la russie et
puis l'alliance atlantique qui qui dit
également renaît de ses cendres alors
antonio gutiérrez vous l'avez diarra
était à bout de chou aujourd'hui la
ville où ont été découverts les premiers
charniers laissé derrière elle par
l'armée russe il est revenu sur l'
enquête en cours à la cour pénale
internationale écoutez
je suis satisfait que la cour pénale
internationale et s'était saisie
je soutiens la cpi
à la russie pour qu'elles acceptent de
coopérer avec elle
mais quand on parle d'un crime de guerre
war crâne il ne faut pas oublier que le
pire des crimes c'est la guerre
elle-même
soit ils sont allés le responsable de la
guerre bien sûr c'est la russie il ya là
françois durr pas une pression
indéniable de la communauté
internationale envers la russie présenté
par tous comme l'agresseur ça c'est
important effectivement qu'on est con et
un discours fort de guti res le sujet
parce que la narration sur ces guerres
allez on le voit occidentale mais ce
n'est peut-être pas la même chose
partout et là on aboutirait ce qui dit
il il ya une atteinte aux droits humains
les plus fondamentaux en gardant sa
neutralité parce qu'il peut pas être
juge et partie mais il est obligé de
dire cela et de le dire avec ses mots en
disant j'imagine ma famille cet endroit
là enfin il sait que ses propos vont
être différemment entendu dans
l'ensemble du monde de ceux de joe biden
il n'est pas le chef de la première
puissance du monde il est le secrétaire
général des nations unies et ça c'est
l'enjeu parce que si cette guerre comme
ça risque d'être lokoka s'enlise dans
une guerre de positions dans une guerre
longue la question de la communauté
internationale va se poser plus déjà
plus d'un humain sur deux si on prend le
total des pays qui n'ont pas condamné
l'action de la russie plus d'un humain
sur deux n'a pas condamné cette
agression est bien là et dans les propos
de joe biden y avait notamment des
indications de l'insécurité alimentaire
il a parlé de cela il a dit il faudra
veiller à ce que alors il pas plus des
américains souvent et c'est vrai qu'ils
oublient un peu le reste du monde mais
ça c'est quand même assez fondamental de
se dire certes il y a des années il ya
des actions qui ont été entreprises par
l'otan les américains sont allés en irak
c'était une atteinte au droit
international la communauté
internationale n'était pas derrière ils
y sont allés seuls ça n'empêche que des
années après vladimir poutine
envahissant l'ukraine co mais aussi un
crémant droit international c'est vrai
que souvent sous la petite musique que
vous entendez dans certaines sociétés
civiles c'est de dire oui mais les
américains ont fait ça oui mais l'otan a
fait ça d'accord en fait le crime de
vladimir poutine demeure pas moins un
crime qui est encore une fois qu'est ce
qu'il se passerait si en fait on ne
réagissait pas à ce que fait blagnac
poutine on imagine bien la chine
envahissant taiwan mais on imagine
n'importe quel pays
envahissant n'importe quel autre sans
aucune conséquence il ya plus de
protection du tout des frontières il ya
donc plus d'ordre international donc il
faut que la communauté internationale se
disent aussi que sur l'insécurité
alimentaire que si déjà on voit déjà les
problèmes qui se posent mais si dans les
semaines qui viennent et dans les mois
qui viennent il ya des soucis ne pas
oublier que ce sont des soldats russes
alors évidemment c'est le ccas
ça me fait douter mais on sait que le
soldat russe il n'a pas tellement le
choix il avance où il prend une balle
derrière de ses officiers ce sont des
soldats rush qui bloque le blé et le
maïs ukrainien ce ne sont pas les
ukrainiens et donc là dessus il faut que
la communauté internationale s'interroge
sur les responsabilités alors justement
ces sanctions occidentales elle était
censée dissuader la russie dans son
offensive or et bien gasprom voit son
bénéfice s'envoler certes pour l'année
dernière à 28 milliards mais on voit
bien que ce n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter
avec la hausse des prix du gaz et le
rebond du rouble d'ailleurs à on va le
voir sans doute dans un instant revenir
à son niveau d'avant guerre le piège
russe fonctionne bruno moscou profitent
à plein des inquiétudes nées de la
guerre qu'elle a elle même provoqué qui
parfois même à bloquer les
approvisionnements pour pour provoquer
une flambée des taux je crois qu'il est
qu'il est un peu tôt pour se prononcer
parce qu'il peut y avoir des bénéfices
comme on le voit là à court terme après
il faudra voir à long terme ce qui se
passe réellement sur l'économie russe
l'a effectivement le rouble finalement
ne ne s'en sort pas trop mal la position
de la russie à très court terme sur le
gaz fait que effectivement ce prix du
gaz augmente mais là déjà il faudra voir
il n'est pas dit que la russie fasse ce
qu'elle vient de faire à la pologne à la
bulgarie à d'autres états européens
enfin elle perd elle perd des recettes
donc un très court terme c'était un joli
coup de vladimir poutine parce que ça
voulait dire les européens vous un joli
coup politique
vous mettez du temps à vous mettre
d'accord pour savoir si vous faites
l'embargo ou pas boum c'est moi qui
c'est moi qui coupent le robinet enfin à
moyen terme ça va quand même être faut
rappeler les les recettes tirées des
hydrocarbures ces 40% du budget russe
par exemple donc à moyen terme ça va
poser problème donc pour un peu comme
disent les anglais wait and see on verra
wait and see françois durpaire oui à
voir les anglais lee sera sont là jusque
là qu aujourd'hui la ministre des
affaires étrangères c'était encore pire
que joe biden était la géopolitique est
de retour il faut non seulement aider
l'ukraine mais aidé la bulgarie oui
enfin c'était quand même un discours
extrêmement va-t-en-guerre est
effectivement très très très très dur
la situation aujourd'hui c'est on le
voit bien d'ailleurs il ya une question
qui relève un peu de notre ressort de
des rédactions occidentales et des
journalistes c'est que si cissé guerre
dure deux mois trois mois quatre mois
cinq mois six mois est ce qu'elle va
continuer à faire le coeur de
l'actualité c'est important aussi de
savoir ça parce que je disais le
carburant du discours de joe biden s'est
aussi les mois de la de l'opinion de
l'opinion américaine
mais messi dans un mois deux mois trois
mois les ukrainiens sont son seul face
au monde et qu'on ne regarde plus du
côté de l'ukraine c'est peut-être là que
les enjeux véritablement de cette guerre
vont se poser merci françois durpaire je
crois que vous devez y aller parce que
l'heure où il a et on approche un peu
gras ténor merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci également bruno daroux c'est à
fond on va plus loin en se retrouvant
c'est toujours affectées entre nous on
se retrouve dans un instant pour un
nouveau journal dans paris direct